TV is about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Rosanna Lockwood here on uncensored
tonight now it's one of the most
defining and devices issues of our time
the migrant crisis how do countries
safely solve this issue stop boats and
convoys and help liberate those at the
mercy of human traffickers we'll be
debating that
fighting for women's rights in sport
I'll be joined by Canadian power lifter
April Hutchinson who was threatened with
suspension for speaking out against
trans women competing in her sport she's
going to be joining us live
and he's back for round two on
uncensored Jeremy Corbell investigative
journalist and podcast host is going to
join me to talk about why we should all
take this Potential Threat from UFOs
more seriously
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening and
welcome to Piers morganland center with
me Rosanna Lockwood back in the chair
for another week fears still on holiday
now migrants the failure to stop illegal
migration to the UK that really is the
story of the moment because this
government's much shouted about stopped
the boat's agenda is a massive massive
failure their supposed small boats week
which was last week saw the first
migrants boarding the Bibi Stockholm
barge just off the coast of Dorset
before they had to rapidly disembark it
following a Legionella outbreak at least
six more people died in the channel over
the weekend and now hearing ever more
frenzied cries from some quarters to
Simply turn the boats back
and look it's not a fix is it remember
this was one of the prime minister's
five pledges Rishi sunette promising
everyone that he would get control of
the borders what I hear when someone
says well you know if someone comes here
and claims Asylum illegally they can't
be illegal in the claiming aside am I
hear that so that's wrong right when I
hear that someone has paid thousands of
pounds to come here and exploit our
world-leading modern slavery laws that's
wrong we have to fix all those things
the system that we need the system that
I want to introduce is one whereby if
you come here illegally you should be
swiftly detained and then in a matter of
days or weeks we will hear your claim
not months and years and then we will
safely remove you somewhere else and if
we do that that's how we'll break the
cycle Richie students speaking to our
very own peers Morgan there and this
idea and it's not Pierce's words but
it's words from other parts of the media
at the moment about just turn the boats
back when they're halfway across the
channel why can't we do that it's not a
fix because that would be like painting
over a crack in a wall rather than
dealing with the crumbling foundations
that led to it and let me be clear what
I'm saying here the crumbling
foundations are not the desperate humans
risking their lives to get here the
crumbling Foundation is the almost
criminal inadequacy of this government's
failure to ensure an asylum processing
system that provides safe tested and
legal routes for arrivals and then you
get this breeding ground for actual
criminal gangs to exploit people into
making the journey here now the two
principal smuggling routes for migrants
trying to reach the UK are from Syria
into turkey and from east north and West
Africa to Europe Asylum Seekers are then
reportedly paying as little as 500
pounds for a spot on a small boat to
make the dangerous journey across the
channel from northern France to the
coast in Kent
the UN estimates the global network of
illegal migration generates a minimum
minimum of 6.75 billion dollars a year
for criminals according to those
estimates that they found there is no
single way people smuggling is done it's
Myriad but it often involves violence
threats falsified ID documents dangerous
uses of lorries and boats for Transit of
people in order to stop these criminals
we need action at every single stage of
the journey that they take from The
Source country to the destination and we
obviously cannot do it alone the saying
goes no man is an island well
technically this country the UK is a big
island or a series of islands but we
cannot be entirely self-sufficient in
this it's a mistake to think we can just
by strengthening our borders like with
some sort of medieval castle that can
pull up a drawbridge nor is it France's
problem just because they're our closest
neighbor and the last point before many
illegal migrants reach the UK it is
every single country in every Authority
at all parts of the journey and that is
going to take some serious grown-up
International coordination last week
amid all this Bibby Stockholm nonsense
the government actually announced a deal
with turkey to set up a Joint Force
Center there to disrupt and dismantle
some of these horrendous people
smuggling gangs now if that is done
right I'd say that's far more important
and useful than a big horrible barge off
the coast of Dorset which is nothing but
a massive totem of failure and last
resort on tonight's show we're going to
understand a bit more about these
criminal gangs how they operate how much
they make and what they do to people and
how they might be stopped joining me to
discuss all of this is Dr Andy hojay an
expert in EU law and migration at
University College London also joining
us here in the studio socialist and
author Grace Blakely and we're also
joined down the line by author and
podcast host Constantine kitchen
Constantine thank you I'll start with
you soon as you're there you were just
listening uh to my opener to the show
there
do you think that's fair that the
government's just got its focus in the
wrong direction here
I think what we should be doing is uh
working with countries like turkey Egypt
Etc to create refugee camps in those
countries near the conflict zones and
then uh process the people there but I'm
afraid even when we do that and even
when we do create legal and safe routes
as you say what will happen is some
people will still try to get into this
country illegally so we are going to
have to you said we shouldn't think
about strengthening our borders I
actually think we should we should
provide safe and legal means for people
to apply but there will still be people
who want to come here uh by breaking the
rules and that should not be tolerated
yeah I'd like to be clear with that so
strengthening borders I do mean Asylum
processing I do mean regarding each and
every application thoroughly I call that
strength inner borders not necessarily
military troops and things like that
which are sometimes suggested I mean but
the question you have to answer then
Rosanna is once we have those safe and
legal routes in place what are you going
to do with people who try to get in
illegally when they will do I'm afraid
at the end of the day we are going to
have to find some way of preventing
people from getting into this country he
mentioned where an island it actually
shouldn't be as hard as it now seems
Let's cross to some of our guests in the
studio Dr Andy uh joining us because you
would deal in very legal aspects of this
you deal with migration on that very
real basis give us a sense of the
criminal gang element to this how
serious it is it's quite serious because
organized crime has arranged many of
these trips they still have a very
strong foothold in France and across the
wider region which you were calling in
Turkey as well as the Western Balkan
routes and the other one behind who
actually organized the trips what we saw
from last year's Crossing as well as
this year Crossing we could see how they
advertise the routes actually in
different languages and they use all
sort of social media networks and even
in some local TV channels in different
parts of the world where they are sort
of advertising The Roots so they are
fairly sophisticated in terms of how
they're organized the trip and how they
promote their criminal activities now
the UK government has tried last year
a little bit this year it seems to be a
bit more prepared at the start of the
summer season because what we saw from
last year usually during the summer is
where the numbers rise up and we can see
exactly the same this year but it seems
that still we are in ill-sufficient and
Ill prepared and that would require a
lot of collaboration with many countries
across Europe because more we can see
the route starts from Turkey up to
France and they arrive here so there's a
number of countries that we can deal
better and we can collaborate them but
also the countries where they come from
I mean that's also the big question
right so I mean it's a huge uh
International task requiring a hell of a
lot of collaboration do you think this
government's got it in them well at the
moment there seems that are playing
catch-up and they're merely reactive to
a specific situation rather than
preparing one would think that this year
they would be far more prepared than
they were last year but it seems that
they did not learn from some of those
mistakes now we can see around Europe
even the European Union is having a
discussion in terms of how he should
allocate migrants and they tried before
the summer to make a new deal in terms
of how they are going to allocate and
they still cannot fully accept or agree
what would be the correct number right
so that does also put a challenge in
terms of for us but the question per se
or in the debate are we talking here
about migrant as the numbers that
they're coming here or are we talking
about migrant splits problems that has
to be clearly defined because if we're
talking about numbers it's not per se
the numbers but what sort of skill set
do these migrants have have what sort of
integration programs we can provide for
them because if they come with low
skilled background it would be really
difficult to to integrate them into our
society and that's something that the UK
should not very much look forward to
right so this really requires a lot of
global efforts and a proper study should
be conducted but so far we assume that
we are playing catch-up along the way it
feels catch up it feels reaction like
you said it's not just about a numbers
game humans are invariably incredibly
different and can offer different things
to a country and come from different
backgrounds have different stories about
why they came here Grace
um in terms of the numbers the
government is out of control on this the
numbers have been rising rapidly over
the last few years in terms of the
number of of illegal migrants they're
making their way to the UK can you
understand why this is becoming such a
huge political issue okay I think we
really need to kind of take a step back
and look at the situation a bit more
objectively because the framing is
always there's a migrant crisis there's
hordes of people coming over let's just
bear in mind that the vast majority of
refugees around the world are in the
global South they're in poor countries
they're largely in countries around
conflict zones and around places where
you've had these processes of long-term
social decay of War of extreme poverty
and also now of climate breakdown you
know these people are being forced out
of one place and pushed into another now
some of those people are then able to
make the long and dangerous route a
route which they ultimately think is
going to be worth it a route for which
they save a long long time root for
which they often risk their lives to get
out of what are often horrendous
conditions in refugee camps in some of
the poor parts of the world they make
their way painstakingly through all
these different places get around all
these barriers to try and get to the UK
and the idea that somehow we would solve
this problem by as you say kind of
constructing a castle or like putting a
four around our country or doing like
literally like building a wall around
England is utterly absurd isn't it you
know it's the same with any of these
questions around uh crime and prevention
and illegality if you just focus on
enforcement and you don't think about
what's driving the issue if you don't
think about what's driving people to to
try to come to this country risking
their lives to do so paying lots of
money to do so and if you don't organize
ways for that process to be handled
cooperatively with the you know UK
working with governments around the
world then nothing's going to change
let's bring in Constantin on this who's
been listening in carefully uh to those
comments made by Grace uh Constantin
because I would argue and Grace I will
give you an opportunity to come back as
well that you've got to do both at the
same time look at the source issue that
causes migration people to leave their
own countries but also deal with the
issue that is very upfront which is
everyday thousands of people sometimes
arriving
yes well we have to deal with both I'm
glad by the way that Grace made the
distinction between refugees and
migrants I'm increasingly uncomfortable
as we talk about these people as
migrants uh these some of these people
are refugees many of these people are
simply illegal immigrants and as someone
who followed the immigration system of
this country to come here many years ago
I'm increasingly frustrated that we're
conflating people who are breaking the
law of this land to get here uh with
everybody else who follows the process
as they should so that's the first point
I made the second point I think you're
right we have to provide some method for
people to apply in areas there already
are places like turkey like Egypt Etc
but then we have to recognize that not
everybody who's attempting to get into
Britain is actually a refugee I mean
we've seen a huge influx of albanians
for example Albania is not a war-torn
country Albania is not a country that's
uh it's a source of refugees
particularly so there is different types
of immigrants who are attempting to come
here different types of people and we
have to find them where they are they
can apply and then we have to actually
hear their claim and not everybody's
going to meet the conditions for Refugee
status and we have to recognize that yes
of course we've got to be able to help
people but on the other hand not
everybody who's attempting to get in is
actually going to qualify which is one
of the reasons that they're doing it
illegally if you think about when we
talk about safe and legal routes all the
time one of the things that people don't
seem to say is there are plenty of safe
and legal routes you could simply go to
a visa center or and apply to get in
here like any other immigrant the reason
people are doing this is many of them
will not qualify and we are going to
have to reckon with that as well it is
it is I want to come to Dr Andy in the
studio because he's done a lot of work
regarding Albania and I think it's
important that Constantin and Grace have
brought up the point of Distinction but
they're between Asylum Seekers refugees
migrants illegal migrants Etc when it
comes to Albania um it is a country that
has been in the press a lot because of
the amount of Albanian migrants legal
illegal or otherwise have ended up here
and the government has tried to the UK
government to find a strategy to deter
how successful has that been with regard
to Albania so
we have to sort of Distinction I'm glad
that we made the distinction between uh
Refugee migrants but as well as those
who have been trafficked in this country
when it comes to the case of Albania the
UK government and Albania did
acknowledge that there was an issue
around a illegal migration and they made
an agreement and what we found out
actually the two countries didn't really
have a lot of relation when it comes to
specific issues such as migration both
where member of NATO's but we didn't see
many collaboration the moment that we
saw both government start together and
actually acknowledge that some of these
issues could have been tackled together
we can see the numbers this year have
reduced dramatically so if we Compare
the numbers this year to last year there
is a decrease on the number and that is
because there was an acknowledgment
however I can see the word being thrown
around well what we did with Albania
let's say it with other countries but we
have to cut through a little bit on this
do we think that we can make a deal with
Afghanistan how we did with Albania
because their talibans are in charge
right and so far no one is sitting with
them right we see with Syria and other
countries as well you just put the
number of how many different
nationalities have arrived this year and
many of them are countries that the UK
doesn't have a very good or friendly
relation like they did with Albania with
Albania was very different and it was
possible to achieve it because both
countries are NATO members right and
there were many already the sort of
political framework was already in place
it was just about putting a bit more
effort Grace
um I did promise to come back to you we
are shortly running out of time but on
that point of going to source as you
were saying when Dr Anthony bought the
Afghanistan example there the six
migrants that died in the channel over
the weekend were from Afghanistan
obviously the chaotic withdrawal of U.S
forces from Kabul the Taliban taking
over a few years ago these are not quick
fixes to an issue I think it's really
important that we remember that it's not
as easy for many people as just you know
showing up at a an office of a
government and then you know applying
for for a legal route to get to the UK
or to Europe because a lot of these
migrants are from places where there is
literally the absence of a state or a
failed state or a crumbling state or a
state that's in conflict or a pariah
state or you know a state which would
simply not allow them to kind of even
begin to start making that Journey so
the distinction shouldn't just be
illegality or legality it shouldn't just
be how did they come into the country
was it on a boat or was it on a train It
kind of doesn't make sense to categorize
people in that way does it it should be
where have they come from you know what
is their need and how can we work to
actually integrate those people into our
society
um and yeah you know like use their
skills and the resources that these
people have for the UK because we need
people to work in the NHS we need people
to do jobs for which we currently have
large amounts of vacancies so why not
actually create those routes where
people to come into this country either
because they are in need in their
fleeing conflict their fleeing war or
because they have the skills that we
need uh you know in the NHS or
potentially both immigrants is basic
economics you need immigrants to prop up
most countries and economies it's been
interesting discussion that Grace Dr
Andy and Constantin thanks all three of
you uncensored next to night I'm going
to be speaking to Team Canada's female
powerlifter April Hutchinson about the
stand she's taking in her sport against
men identifying as women
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to uncensored with me
Rosanna Lockwood now in March the U.S
power lifting governing body ruled they
would allow trans women to compete in
female competitions north of the Border
in Canada the rules however seem to be
very relaxed with reports that athletes
can compete under whatever gender they
feel like on any given day apparently
with no proof needed other than
self-identification now April Hutchinson
is a competitive power lifter she's now
speaking up claiming it's unfair to
biological women and she's even been
threatened with a ban from her sport for
expressing her views she says an Andrus
a trans woman currently holds the
highest deadlift of all time in Canada
and just announced she will attempt to
go to the world championship so should
we Embrace inclusivity in sports uh are
women failing to be protected in sports
April Hutchison joins us now to talk
through this April uh thank you very
much for making time to speak to us now
you're a very busy woman you've actually
just been competing in Grand Cayman I
hope that went well for you and just
talk to us a little bit for an
international audience give us a sense
of what you're campaigning about
yeah so actually um I've been a power
lifter with the Canadian uh part of the
thing Union for about four years now
over the last year I have been basically
I guess fighting my Federation
um to ban I guess trans women
um also known as men to be competing
with women in in powerlifting they have
basically ignored my pleas as well as
many other women who don't agree with it
and they've actually even threatened to
suspend me for speaking up about the
matter
um I don't know if you saw my speech a
couple weeks ago I was in the USA and I
basically told a very heartfelt speech
about you know the discriminate or the
basically them the threatening me to
suspend me off of Team Canada
um I just competed last week with Team
Canada I was allowed to go but the the
threats keep coming and um you know
disciplinary action for speaking up has
been ongoing for the last year do you
think this is a specific difference
between the US and Canada or other
countries in Canada is Canada
particularly inclusive when it comes to
this
yeah that's the thing is
um Canada I mean I'm not going to use
the Expression woke but I mean we have a
prime minister here Justin Trudeau who
actually on International women's day
tweeted that trans women are women so
there's our leadership of the country
um but no Canada is very
um I guess very lenient with with
policies like you mentioned our policy
basically you do not need any proof my
boyfriend could basically walk in
tomorrow identify as a female compete
and then the next day you know go back
to being a man again no proof no ID
required just basically going on how you
feel that day or whatever gender you
want to identify as yeah mind our
viewers just a few months ago a
powerlifting coach Avi silverberg
actually did this uh went into a
competition I think in Canada and
basically it competed as a man and
smashed it
here he is and he didn't say I'm a woman
or maybe he did just to get past the uh
the regulations but did it in order to
prove your point really April didn't he
that um a man can just walk into a
competition and just trans trance
everyone there but let's make a
distinction here with Anne Andrus who we
we talked about in the introduction to
you that's somebody you know personally
and that is seems to be a source of a
lot of angst here this is Anne Andrews
competing uh a trans woman or as you you
call a trans identifying person uh
previously born a biological male
transitioned a long time ago but post
puberty and I believe that's correct and
uh is uh taking on a lot of Records
um talk to us about what that's been
like for you
yeah so Anne actually just broke the the
national records for all the master
records yesterday while competing at the
Western regions
he also holds the second highest
deadlift in uh our powerlifting
Federation of all time of all ages we're
talking 20 and up
um he just turned 40 so he is a 40 40
year old uh six foot 250 pound man and
you know it's it's been very
disheartening
um for example that National Record that
he broke
athletes have been chasing that for
years and we're talk we're talking top
athletes who have been training and
training and training
um you know so it just goes to show the
advantages the physical physiological
advantages that a male has over a female
whether it's muscle mass or bone density
lung capacity you know I could go on but
um it's been very disheartening a lot of
women actually yesterday dropped out of
the competition because they knew that
Anne would be lifting so they dropped
they quit they wrote to the Federation
and the Federation basically did nothing
about it I can understand the enormous
frustration to be a correct because when
it comes to sports and it's all about
the the physicality of what you're doing
and to put it simply it's just it it
must be terribly frustrating especially
in power lifting which is so much to do
with strength and like why do you think
powerlifting is behaving differently
here you're talking about your
Federation compared to other sports when
it comes to things that swimming in
athletics where internationally we have
seen different policy lives
you know what Rosanna it's it's
mind-boggling we ask ourselves that
every day because I was talking to a
couple of the doctors the chief medical
doctors uh with the international
powerlifting Federation who right now
are actually working so hard around the
clock to try to have the policy changed
you have a new Senate powerlifting is a
strength based sport there's a 60
advantage in powerlifting alone between
men and female
um you know we've seen us UCI cycling
has changed just recently the
international weightlifting Federation
has now created a separate category for
transgender and that's with the the
Olympic lifting right that's a little
different than power of the thing but
still a strength sport uh World
Athletics swim Canada every Federation
has even gotten rid of the testosterone
monitoring that's that's been kind of
like as a term an outdated policy right
now so I just I don't get why
powerlifting especially my Federation
why they are not uh you know they must
be afraid probably to get sued possibly
um you know it's it's mind-boggling I
ask myself that question every day April
um just before we let you go what do you
hope to achieve uh what would you like
to see happen within the next few months
well you know what my main goal you know
even if I wasn't powerlifting I my main
goal is to have fairness for women in
sports around the world globally Canada
is probably on the top of the list
because we have no policy we actually
have a trans inclusion policy we have no
policy at all to protect women and girls
and sports so I mean if I if I put
powerlifting to the back door tomorrow
and I didn't powerlift ever again so be
it but I will keep being vocal and I
will keep speaking out about fairness
because we know women deserve that it's
completely unfair it's bodies that play
sports not identities remember it's
bodies in biology not identities that
play sports uh April I think it would be
a tremendously sad if you find yourself
with joy from the sport but we really
appreciate you sharing your views and
your experience this evening thank you
thank you so much well let's cross to
the studio still joined by Grace Blakely
also talk TV contributor Esther cracker
who are both listening into that and
look I know we've all potentially got
very different positions on this uh but
we are all women uh my position is that
you know obviously I'm pretty
sympathetic to trans rights and I feel
they're a marginalized and oppressed
group mostly but when it comes to sport
it's a little more complicated because
of the physicality of it Grace yeah I
don't disagree I mean I think you know
this quite obviously this has become a
culture War actually right so it's like
you're either on one extreme or the
other you're either for trans women be
able to compete in sports or you're
against it
um and actually this is very clearly
something that needs to be decided by
sporting bodies on a case-by-case basis
and also on a literally on a
case-by-case basis so you need to be
looking at the athlete in question
looking at whether or not there is one
person dominating a sport and then it
just becomes not entertaining to watch
so you need to think about how you're
doing the rules there and it's not just
trans people it's also intersex people I
remember we had the South African runner
who was bad from competing exactly on
the basis she had high testosterone
levels so clearly we're at this point
now where because often because
um you know competitive sports like this
have grown so much and they've become so
much more popular there's a range of
different people competing that the
rules which gave rise to the separation
of men and women's sports are being
reconsidered and do we need to now think
of something like you know we're testing
athletes based on
um maybe you know like hormone levels
testosterone levels along with other
metrics of how their body performs under
stress along with thinking about you
know if they're trans if they transition
pre or post teenager Hood like all of
these things need to be decided very
specifically not just this culture War
you know battle I mean the lady said
something which is I think is probably
the the Pinnacle of this debate which is
biology over identity on the issue of
intersex people yes I do think it should
be a case-by-case basis and people are
born with you know chromosomal disorders
and all of that that's that's fine
that's biology right but on the issue of
of transgenderism that's an identity
issue right it's also a biology well
it's not a violence we also our
biologies all the time but the thing is
we take the pill with they are not
fundamentally they're not altering every
single cell in their body which is every
single cell in your body is a marker of
what your sex is so that's completely
different on the issue of intersex I
don't think you can I you know conflate
that with transgenderism because you
can't choose to be intersex you can
choose to be transgender well I mean
people would argue that you can't but I
think regardless but that that is that
is the bottom line I think obviously and
I I know we all we all agree that at
some point in the weeks or weeks or
months that we do this job we will talk
about trans issues and we're just like
why again because we haven't simplified
what the rule should be and this is the
thing we're not most people don't
disagree I've always said there should
be a trans category for most sports not
because I'm going to be sitting at the
front room watching but because this was
just this will solve the whole debate
the get representation they get to
compete there is no you know issue of
how female athletes feel or male
athletes or any of this there's none of
this confusion and they get to compete
and they get to feel represented I don't
know why we're not championing that more
championing that more that would solve
this whole problem but really if we keep
going down to oh but it's not my fault
I'm trans or whatever look you have your
own league case closed let's talk about
the economy or taxes you know I'll
always talk about the economy a lot of
my numbers me uh both of you thank you
very much for giving your Insight and
the opinion on that story uh yes we do
cover this issue a lot but I think it
was very interesting to hear Bill
Hutchinson's experience uh this evening
uncensored next to night investigative
journalist Jeremy Corbell will be live
and on Center we're going to be talking
UFOs and how seriously we should be
taking any Potential Threat that's
coming up next
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah King peers and
King Cube I think it's only one for one
king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're kinfo
do you believe you can win this war are
you making me cry again I'm trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
King Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
the knock-on effect is far larger than
just CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know I know you're
probably going to vote me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
welcome back to uncensored now to UFOs
and revisiting this topic in fact
because this time last week we invited
two experts on to talk about the recent
Congressional Hearing in the U.S which
included testimony from a Former
Intelligence official who claimed the
U.S has possession of intact and
partially intact alien vehicles
I actually asked to do this topic while
covering this seat for peers because I
find it really interesting and last
week's interview didn't go as planned
sometimes in live televisions that
happens we ran short of time to get to
ask the questions I wanted we got some
feedback from the community that follows
uh the guests that we invited on that
they weren't appreciative of the way we
handled it so we decided to invite the
investigative journalist and co-host of
the weaponized podcast Jeremy Corbell
back onto this show joins us now Jeremy
welcome back and just uh give me a sense
of exactly where you think the interview
didn't go the way that was hoped last
time
yeah Rosanna I I really appreciate you
I've heard that that you are smart and
that you listen to the public and that
you are trying to report the news so
let's reframe this conversation I think
that you have been unfairly attacked on
social media due to our last discussion
you know I am not as hell and I'm not
going to take it anymore if you remember
that movie I remember very well Jeremy
Network yeah
weapons and so that's why I'm back on
but let's talk about why I'm back on
last time it was like a Twilight Zone
movie mixed with like The Wizard of Oz
is like that film don't look up I was
sitting there thinking what are they
doing saying tin foil hat what are they
doing playing The X-Files music we are
so far past that but this is a battle
for information right now and I said you
know so put on your battle helmet so
let's talk about that real quick
um what I meant to try to talk with you
about is that this is an international
issue and no matter what is found about
this UFO topic whatever the the ground
level truth is this is the biggest story
in human history no matter what it is
found that UFOs are or represent to
humanity they now call them UAP no big
deal but I want to throw down for you
right now so you understand you might
not be aware there is a literal
disinformation campaign by intelligence
agencies to quote unquote shape the
emerging UAP narrative and they use
stigma and sleight of hand and your
government is actually involved in this
and before today really your network and
you have been kind of unwittingly part
of this problem but as of today right
now this conversation your network
we are now going to make sure you are
part of the solution because we're going
to be talking about the facts of the UFO
and UAP issue and I I am personally
aware of the impacts of this last UFO
hearing are you personally aware of the
repercussions what happened because of
that UFO hearing no I'm not and again
this is the reason why I wanted to have
this discussion because I thought it was
so rare and unusual to see uh Congress
taking the issue of UFOs so seriously in
fact let's play a clip from uh some
testimony we had
if you believe we have crashed craft uh
stated earlier do we have the bodies of
the pilots who piloted this craft
biologics came with some of these
recoveries yeah were they I guess human
or non-human biologics non-human and
that was the assessment of people with
direct knowledge on the program I talked
to that are currently still on the
program
Jeremy give our audience a sense if
they're not familiar with this because
not everyone has the level of detail
inside the you and your followers have
into this whole community and into the
experts involved who that person was
yeah again questions are weapons so
thank you for throwing that one to me so
you see on your screen David grush a
decorated military veteran who has
served the United States and
intelligence communities for decades and
this individual came forward under oath
under oath came forward and he said look
I did an investigation I had access to
these special access programs it was my
job to look for misappropriation of
funds which is theft related to UFOs and
UAP and he found them he interviewed
over 40 people that had Direct
first-hand knowledge of a cover-up of
these UFO programs exploitation which
means reverse engineering so we got
there in front of Congress and for the
first time in history had first-hand
people two pilots fighter pilots Top Gun
Pilots think Tom Cruise who one of whom
engaged the UFO for the United States
military and then we had David Gray
question David gresh is a whistleblower
about the this theft from our
government's financially to cover up
this UFO exploitation or reverse
engineering thing and he just said there
in that clip that there were biologics
he means Pilots non-human intelligence
now if that is true whatever you want to
label what he said we need to find out
if that is true so we held this historic
Congressional hearing those three
individuals testified under oath and my
mentor in journalism George Knapp and I
we submitted something for Congressional
Record two statements and those
statements were an assessment of the
situation that has been going on for a
long time regarding UFOs and the
cover-up let's give
it's a bit of a sense then of one of
those Pilots you were saying it's almost
like a sort of top gun person a real
pilot uh Ryan Graves this is what he
said
in 2014 I was an F-18 foxtrot pilot in
the Navy fighter attack Squadron 11 the
red rippers after upgrades were made to
our Jets radar systems we began
detecting unknown objects operating in
our airspace
during a training mission in morning
area whiskey 72 10 miles off the coast
of Virginia Beach two F-18 Super Hornets
were split by UAP
the object described as a dark gray or a
black Cube inside of a clear sphere came
within 50 feet of the lead aircraft and
was estimated to be 5 to 15 feet in
diameter now that's some pretty
interesting and serious testimony in my
ears when it comes to this and you talk
it there about government cover-up which
is actually one of the sort of uh topics
why we had this hearing it's been also
called quote administrative terrorism
you said the UK government is complicit
in that of course they're not here to
give any kind of counter to that but
we're gonna listen to your point of view
on it or the facts that you've gathered
but the thing that I sort of pricked my
ears up over the last week when I've
been receiving all this commentary
online was that this idea of don't look
up which of course is that movie about
people not taking climate change
seriously notably TV shows like this one
um and I take climate change very
seriously and off the back of that
Congressional hearing took UFOs more
seriously as well so what is it you need
to do you think to get people to
continue to take this topic seriously
and see it for the interest that it has
well I I commend you Rosanna because
this is what exactly we need to do is
bring people up to date with what we
know what we think and what we're trying
to find out so I really like that you
referenced that movie because this is
nothing new people have been coming
forward for a long time there's just now
an official process to protect
whistleblowers under a presidential
protection act so peop this is
legislation and that legislation wasn't
made out of a void this is so people can
come forward and say I have been
complicit in this cover-up about UFOs
that this has been happening for a long
time it's ubiquitous across the globe
and it presents not only safety of
flight issues but also issues with
deployments issues with nuclear weapons
this is well documented that there has
been interference from unknowns from
Craft of Unknown Origin that outpace
outmaneuver and outperform anything we
have in our Arsenal as well as the UK
Arsenal and how I say and why I say that
the UK is is involved in this is because
of the five eyes Alliance because I
released with my mentor in journalism
George Knapp evidence and proof of this
from Canada that there is something
called the the foreign Technologies
program that is absolutely 100 working
on these reverse engineering programs of
uaps it's called the foreign materials
program the five eyes foreign materials
program and this was a a minister a
parliamentary member from Canada that
wrote this letter in deep concern so
this is something the UK the U.S the
five eyes alliances have all been
working on and this has been going on
for a long time so what has to happen
now is we need to reduce the stigma no
more X-Files no more tinfoil hats again
put on your battle helmets what's
important now is we find out the ground
truth on UFOs we know UFOs are real we
know there are machines that are far
more advanced than what we have and this
is nothing new these have been reported
reported before the Wright brothers went
into the to the sky before human beings
have flight this has been reported by
pilots by military some of these
accounts they go back to before there
was even a pentagon so now we have to
have this conversation soberly we need
to discuss the facts because our sensor
systems it's not just Pilots anymore
telling you this the pilots are simply
corroborating what's on their shared AI
radar this is something that's being
picked up this is something that we have
corroborative Visual Evidence of a lot
of which I have produced and put to the
public through leaks that came to me
they have been verified by our
Department of Defense so everybody what
you can do is start paying attention
keeping those eyes open and having sober
discussion of facts and to take a listen
to some of those clips in the
Congressional hearing are fascinating
and Jeremy it's been a fascinating
discussion thank you so much for making
time to speak to us again
anytime I really appreciate you people
got it wrong you're doing your job
you're reporting the news and this is
the biggest story of all time thanks
Jeremy
while on scented next tonight I'll be
joined by my pack we're going to be
discussing the Crackdown on
gender-neutral toilets of whether or not
the fight of the centuries that we must
will ever happen and the ban on poor
tipping from French Riviera restaurants
that's all coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
coming up on the talk the government
doubles down on its migrant barge policy
as it's reported there have been violent
clashes in migrant camps in France new
rules are announced to protect
single-sex toilets and knives are being
sold to school children online for less
than two pounds that's all at nine
o'clock
thank you
foreign
welcome back to uncensored joined in the
studio by the Monday night pack
socialist and author Grace Blakely joins
us again talktv contributor Esther
Krakow also makes a way back into the
studio and comedian James Barr joins us
too let's dice up some of the stories
from today then shall we it's a huge
range and let's start with gender
because that's something we never
discussed again
the gender agenda
gender neutral toilet clamp down
equalities Minister Kami Bay denuck
who's also a Secretary of State for
business has been very busy talking
about toilets today here in the United
Kingdom saying women will have their own
toilets in all new non-residential
buildings in a bid to protect Single Sex
spaces she said the proposals will
ensure every building in England
provides separate male of female or
unisex facilities and they're going to
publish guidance about it what'd you
make of this Chris oh it's so pathetic
from the government isn't it it's so
obviously an attempt to distract from
just the appalling job it's doing on
almost every metric from economic to
social to cultural and it's just a kind
of look over the hair strategy we're
doing something about bathrooms it's a
bid to basically try and get people
angry about something that is compared
to literally almost anything else that
is going on anywhere in our society
anywhere in our environment anywhere in
our economy just not a big deal I I when
I when I when I read this I just thought
that's quite pathetic like not not in
the sense that I disagree with that you
know I like to have my own space I've
always thought that the idea of you know
opening a pad or knowing that there's a
man next to me I just don't like Unity
so for me it just I've always felt
uncomfortable with it but I just thought
the Tories must be so desperate this is
what they need to differentiate
themselves I agree I think it's
absolutely pathetic but if they want to
protect women really they should be
doing something about all of the penises
walking around number 10 Downing Street
are the people attached to them
um
uh you can't you know protect against
that with gender-neutral bathrooms Kenny
James look do you not accept Grace that
some people are worried about this they
are bothered by it I think people are
some people are bothered to buy it um
but if you look at the change that
there's been over the last let's say
like five years the old people five
years ago they said basically you know
I'm broadly finding people doing what
they want I think most people have the
same attitude are just like do what you
want it doesn't really affect me that
much I don't really think that much
about which bath am I going to but now
this is my question but like the thing
is is that now after this five years of
culture War people do have more extreme
attitudes about it and that is what
culture or agenda issues are supposed to
they're supposed to push people towards
extremes and make us fight over
something that doesn't matter so that we
don't pay attention to the issues that
do I mean I do agree we're not paying
enough attention to the things that
matter I just you know and I get it I I
like I said I personally don't like
unisex unless I despise them is that
something that I would legislate would
you vote on that basis on that basis
exactly I should qualify it's not
legislation it's guidance
um but uh James is it just the fact that
we're all quite young the four of us
here there are other people in Britain
that think differently uh no I think
it's exactly what we've all been
discussing actually I think
we're all right honestly like um hate
crimes are up by 52 I think think or
even higher two LGBT people were stabbed
outside of a gay bar in London this
weekend the stuff that they say is
having a real effect on people's lives
and they don't care that snabbing was
particularly concerning it was in
Clapham over the weekend uh two gay men
near a pub
um and let's talk then about this NHS
bosses telling emergency workers to
avoid using the words sir or Madam now I
know we've all kind of said look we're
kind of tired of this cultural
distraction uh this one does stripe its
little odd NHS bosses have told 999
operators to avoid calling people sir or
Madam in case they upset trans patients
because to my limited understanding of
not being a trans person they wouldn't
really mind if they were called Sarah
you know what's interesting about the
story this was across many emergency uh
services so it wasn't just like sort of
one you know NHS emergency service in
one County or whatever it was across
many so I just thought wow that's
strange do you have not more important
things to worry about I mean I mean it's
very strange anyway
um it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous it's not because quite
you know women's voices men's voices can
get confused anyway like I've been
confused for being a woman on the phone
so it's kind of offensive to everyone
you know for example Rishi soon act
sounds like a douche you know we all
sound different I think it's important I
mean but the thing is you're calling 999
if you're if you're in a
life-threatening situation I'm sorry
like what the person the person's
Assumption of your of your I just can't
wrap my head around why anyone's being
called Sir or mad in a life-threatening
situation I'd just be like hi I'm an
emergency can you help me not like yes
sir or yes Madam it seems like a waste
of syllables in a time I mean yeah
let's let's move on to other people
which you may also consider to be
douchebags uh James Elon the musk
yeah yeah I think we could say that's
really nice you know what I mean a
douche is actually yeah okay let's maybe
not have that problem
Mark Zuckerberg has hit out at Elon Musk
for wasting time over a cage fight
saying it's time to move on while musk
has hinted it could take place the
supposed cage fight in Rome's Coliseum
the Two Social Media Tech Giants have
been floating this idea of a cage fight
for ages in my mind it's just all
attention seeking was never going to
happen it's so stupid like it's just so
dumb and I mean it would be stupid even
if we weren't in the situation now where
you know Elon Musk has effectively
ruined Twitter like sent you know users
numbers through the floors and
advertising revenues through the floor
it you know Mark Zuckerberg obviously
not a great guy like I saw a tweet the
other day ironically enough saying that
the worst thing that Elon Musk has done
has made Mark Zuckerberg by like
comparison look like a relatively okay
guy which I think is probably true do
you agree with that James yeah I think
if Mark Zuckerberg wants Elon to change
his mind he wants to influence him he
should just pick up the phone to his old
friends at Cambridge analytica I'm sure
they could uh get a musk in the rain
at the end of the day
I've always said with at least at least
on musk and twisting he's
thinking he's and now I've seen like
I've
frat boy mentality like oh I feel like
changing this I'm gonna it's a treat
like a Game Boy and just tweak it so I'm
like I've seen too much of Elon Musk to
be like well basically yeah but the
whole the whole because the parties for
charity and apparently the mayor of Rome
has ruled out them doing in the Coliseum
because it's close for renovation so
that's not going to be happening whilst
we're in the midst of ridiculous I want
to get your view on this Esther tipping
in restaurants in the Riviera some of
the hot spots the most exclusive
restaurants they've got secret Doses and
customers who don't leave generous tips
well that's too bad pay your staff
properly don't expect customers to
subsidize your stuff's wages when you
don't want to
I mean if you're in the French Riviera
you can afford a tip Courtney Grace yeah
I find it how's this going to be
enforced like are they literally going
to have people's are they going to spin
the shoes on the wall like it just means
a bit weird but I mean yes obviously
people should tip especially because you
know a lot of uh restaurants and places
will say we'll just pay people the
lowest possible way I mean that's
generally what are you a king Tipper you
know I love it when guys give me the tip
so I am all before tipping
here in the studio this Monday on peers
are extensive whatever you're up to
tonight make sure it's uncensored good
night
[Music]
oh
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah pink pears and
King Q I think there's only one for one
king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
wall this is making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic